Surprisingly, the answer is the car would be logged.
Let's examine why.
The amy object doesn't have a local dot constructor property, but
amy does delegate the van dot prototype.
Van dot prototype is a brand new object that has been set up to
delegate the Car dot.prototype.
That brand new object does not have its own dot constructor property,
much like any object coming out of Object dot create should not.
At best, it is an object that delegates to an object that has its own dot
constructor property.
Car dot prototype has a dot constructor property because every single dot
prototype object that comes for
free with the function when it's created is given one
of these dot constructor properties pointing back to the original function